I'd come back to the fourth part of the
Alan Smith framework I laid out about
the need to have a shared ethical moral
legal vision and above all else a theme
that I go on about in my book which is
the need to move from tunnel vision to
lateral Vision most of the tools that we
developed in the late 20th century
um to make sense of the world like
economic models apologies the honest
because I know you're an economist but
these lovely economic models these
lovely corporate balance sheets these
lovely big data sets are all very
bounded and marked by tunnel vision you
don't need to apologize because I agree
with you
I was trying to needle you but um but
they basically treat everything that
isn't inside the economic model or the
balance sheet as an externality or a
footprint something outside that model
and what I would argue is that one of
the things that went very badly wrong
with a lot of the corporate vision and
the economic models was treating the
environment as an externality they
ignored who was going to pay for the
damage that was created or the cost of
the natural resources they were it's
quite a big flaw in the capitalist
argument then well if you could actually
start measuring that and putting that
into your model so you start to get a
very different vision of
how companies are valued how they're
looking at the world there are ways of
doing that and people are developing
that impact weighted accounting
impact-rated accounting yes
the regulation that you are never going
to be able to have as long as power is
so heavily concentrated
let me give you an example because um I
think we didn't manage to meet Adam this
Hammer because uh half agreed because
everything you just turned me down no
because half of Grace burned down and I
was going from by the way you know that
exactly is what happened actually in
Venice just to not to be and you missed
you missed you missed an important part
of my CV in these days you know I lead
the political party in Greece you
presented me as if I'm an author and
professional I did that that's a
previous life
you aspire to have power no but the
reason why I mentioned the the
speaking of green girls okay
um I also believe that in in green girls
but I also believe in getting big girls
there are things that need to grow and
things that need to dig out like we need
less cement less CO2 lesser of all the
toxic derivatives the toxic fumes right
we need fewer of those things fewer cars
whether they're electric or not more
public transport
but going back to the forest fires in
Greece this summer
Greece is a failed state right but
nevertheless when it comes to profit
making it's very fast so the day after
we were devastated and the Flames died
down
large corporations came
and took over the attempt to prevent
those
forests from becoming mud baths with the
first trains so you think oh that's a
good thing they came to to help Shore up
the you know the soil and all that
first thing they did was to offer
contracts to the local population that
effectively signed all their rights away
for 20 euros a day or
forget that that's
you could expect that the second thing
they did was they are trying to win
new contracts for replanting the forests
using genetically modified trees
that will glow very quickly and they
will give them the opportunity to in in
the context of the green transition
Harvest biomass for the purposes of you
know Green energy
if we allow them to do this
you're going to have under the cover of
green growth you can have the
devastation of the Flora and the Fauna
of the land and the conversion of these
areas in area and so on into victims of
Monsanto payer who will have genetically
poisoned the land while making it very
green now is this a green growth that we
want this is the green growth that this
market-based system not because it's a
market but because it's monsante is not
a market toxic monolith there are
numerous examples of green washing
there's numerous examples of companies
and finances using the green label to do
all kinds of egregious things that I
wouldn't completely agree with however
one of the other reasons I believe in
competition is that I believe in checks
and balances and I don't think we can
sit there and Trust government alone to
turn off green
when back in the 1970s when Milton
Friedman developed his vision of
shareholder capitalism which I do not
agree with there were two things that
were very different one back then people
thought that they could Outsource the
really difficult decisions in life the
social stuff to governments and
companies just worried about their
balance sheets and secondly you did not
have radical transparency and most
people did not know what was actually
happening inside companies today we have
a world where no one actually trusts the
government to get stuff done
and we have a world where all of you
have cell phones with extraordinary
levels of access to information if you
choose and many aspects of corporate
life are subject to radical transparency
the reason that you know so quickly
about what was happening in those
forests is precisely because of this
radical transparency so I come back to
the point
it's not an either or we don't need a
government or companies to be green or
ngos
we actually benefit by having different
groups in society doing this it is a
good thing that actually we're not just
relying on the Greek government alone to
deal with replanting those forests it's
good that we have citizens armed with
cell phones giving you the date you just
quoted and it's good that we've had
companies coming in and feeling the need
to do something about it even if they
are being essentially up driven by less
than virtuous principles and even if
some of the things they're doing are
wrong many of the things that companies
are doing today are better than they
were doing two or three decades ago so
my question to you not Giannis is this
would you wind back the clock and have
companies to go back to where they were
20 or 30 years ago would you only rely
on government the governments we have to
join us green because look back what's
happened in the last decade it ain't
been so good one of the reasons why
companies why governments are under
pressure to come to cop26 and do
something is partly because there is a
shift in Zeitgeist amongst investors and
businesses that reflect social shifts
that comes back